avec nous ce soir mia homsy pdg de
l'institut du québec et charles
milliards pdg de la fédération des
chambres de commerce du québec bonsoir
bonsoir bonsoir mes envies d'abord est
ce que vous diriez que le nouveau
gouvernement qui est le même finalement
doit composer avec une véritable crise
de la main d'oeuvre oui tout à fait
parce qu'en plus on sait que quand on
regarde la démographie c'est juste le
début c'est sûr que des éléments peut
être plus ponctuels plus conjoncturelle
à cause de la pandémie mais des clivages
qui s'installe dans l'économie va avoir
moins de travailleurs de 20 à 64 ans
jusqu'en 2030 les enjeux dans ce système
la santé vont être impressionnant va
falloir absolument changer comme on gère
pis pour les entreprises aussi c'est le
principal frein à la croissance des
entreprises c'est clair jean milliards
pour vous est-ce que le plan libéral va
permettre de combattre la pénurie de
main d'oeuvre
alors le nouveau gouvernement libéral
annoncé qu'ils allaient s'attaquer à la
question dont on jugera au cours des
prochains mois mais je pense que la
principale responsabilité at on regarde
la pénurie 9,2 chose en soi on a plus de
gens qui contribuent marché du travail
où on a plus de processus automatisé qui
demandent moins de gens alors le
gouvernement répond déjà présent avec
des désinvestissements pour stimuler en
trop la numérisation entre des
entreprises mais pour ce qui est d'avoir
plus de gens l'immigration c'est un
dossier important
parfois je me demande pourquoi on en
parle encore de façon conceptuel ce
qu'on a besoin c'est que
opérationnellement ça avance plus
rapidement à ottawa ici a déjà qui
doutent encore de la contribution de
l'immigration à la pénurie de
main-d'oeuvre je vous invite à aller au
salon de l'immigration et de
l'intégration au québec le lieu demain
et aujourd'hui je suis allé aujourd'hui
il y avait une centaine de kiosques en
présentiel des grandes entreprises des
gens de partout dans toutes les régions
du québec alors la communauté d'affaires
les régions s'entendent pour dire que
c'est une des solutions c'est pas la
seule il faut que les politiciens
s'entendent le se chicanent pozo ce
dossier là il ya déjà un historique et
délivre finalement les permis de
résidence permanente que rapidement
possible ok miom si vous nous avez
apporté deux graphiques qui montrent
qu'il ya de moins en moins de chômeurs
disponibles par poste vacant pour
l'ensemble du cac là on le voit baisser
depuis plusieurs trimestres mais ça
c'est les chômeurs donc par poste vacant
on est à 2 2 présentement mais pour le
québec la chute est encore plus marquée
oui mais au québec c'est impressionnant
parce qu'on avait un ratio de chômeurs
par poste d'accord autour de 5 en 2015
2016 puis l'ont aussi inférieur au
canada à 1.5 donc ça veut dire qu'il ya
moins de deux shows merde
oui oui oui il reprenez votre fosse 1.2
il ya moins il ya moins de deux chômeurs
disponibles par poste vacant skis et ski
est un peu inquiétant derrière ça c'est
que youn ofj nombre de chômeurs et aux
nombre de postes vacants donc c'est très
serré comme comme marché du travail mais
aussi on a des plus de chômeurs derrière
ce petit beaucoup de chômeurs de long
terme alors ça va clairement être un
enjeu pour les prochains gouvernements à
quel point charles juillard ça freine la
croissance des entreprises de tenir une
mineure
c'est extrêmement concrètes tous les
sondages qu'on fait toutes les
associations patronales ou syndicales le
montre la réduction des heures
d'ouverture c'est un point très très
tangible et gens en vacances cet été
l'ont vu il ya même un nouveau sport
dans certaines villes du québec se
trouvait une réservation dans un
restaurant donc vraiment dans les heures
d'ouverture c'est un problème mais aussi
beaucoup
d'entreprises qui perdent des contrôles
qu'ils reportent des opportunités
d'affaires alors c'est pas compliqué
pour les appels qu'on a en ce moment on
ne parle que de ça et comment ont
résonné pour vous les promesses de créer
des emplois les partis proposent m un
million d'emplois d'un prochain mandat
c'est une question un peu piège parce
qu'on est toujours en faveur de la
création d'emplois mais je pense qu'on
n'est pas dans des campagnes électorales
comme celle de monsieur boration à
l'époque prométhée 100000 job je pense
que les entrepreneurs car j'ai entendu
ça en plus de prorogation de la pcr se
disent mais sur quelle planète vivent
les politiciens on a besoin de régler
les postes vacants actuelle bien sûr
dans certains dans certains secteurs
insouciance délivrance à l'aérospatiale
il ya de la place pour créer de
nouvelles opportunités mais parce que
l'heure n'est pas aux gars slogan macro
comme sur le parlement nous sommes ici
on a parlé souvent des solutions
formation on va voir millions dans un
instant la formation requalification et
migration automatisée si on est ce
qu'une proposition libérale qui est
porteuse pour vous
les libéraux je pense leur premier
support pour ça c'est vraiment les
places de garderie dans le fonds pour
permettre à tarifs réduits à 10 dollars
comme on a déjà au québec le l'impact au
québec sera pas majeur sur le marché du
travail mais dans le reste du canada oui
ça va permettre à plus de femmes de
travailler pour les personnes de 65 ans
et plus qui veulent travailler il double
dans le fond la location qu'on a déjà au
québec et ses deux premiers slows sont
intéressantes mais elles sont marginales
par rapport à l'ampleur du virage
nécessaire sur la formation au delà des
mots le quand on regarde vraiment le
cadre financier que les montants
associées aux mesures c'est vraiment
vraiment rien que c'est marginal il ya
pas de vie il était plus à la bonne
place il ya quatre ans dans leurs
discours dans leurs actions que
maintenant sur la formation que les
compétences il ya un crédit d'impôt pour
les 1 à nice le dit oui c'est ça donc on
se limite à sont essentiellement les
années les places de garderie c'est les
deux seules propositions avec des
montants qui construction substantielles
qui vise à régler les enchaînements de
l'état doit-il aider et là on va aller
voir chars milliards l'état doit-il
aider les entreprises qui manque de main
d'oeuvre
bien sûr mais en même temps les lions
mais dans un libre marché et les
entreprises ont une responsabilité aussi
mais le gouvernement libéral le monsieur
trudeau a une responsabilité mais qui
trop embrasse mal étreint les ya quand
même grande responsabilité qui incombe
aussi au ministère du travail et de
l'emploi entre autres à québec qu'il
fait très bien d'ailleurs avec plusieurs
programmes de requalification de la main
d'oeuvre alors oui il faut aider mais
comment on en médecine aussi faux pas
nuire et alors je reviens avec sa
fameuse question au lieu de la pcr eux
je sais qu'il ya encore des dizaines de
milliers de personnes qui en ont besoin
mais quand on parle aux entrepreneurs ça
envoie un mauvais signal
honnêtement ça suscite quand même
beaucoup de colère encore alors faut
changer le jeu sait pas si le packaging
de cette mesure là il ya quelque chose
qui accroche un point en terminant le
gouvernement veut moderniser le régime
d'assurance-emploi pour mieux répondre
aux besoins des travailleurs notamment
les travailleurs autonomes en quoi ça va
aider les employeurs à recruter plus de
travailleurs est ce que ça peut avoir un
effet mis aussi sur la pénurie
demandeurs mais moi je vois pas à date
proposé en quoi ça va avoir un impact
positif sur les enjeux de main d'oeuvre
je pense que c'est c'est plus pour
accommoder les travailleurs qui pour
être mieux adaptée aux enjeux et aux
besoins mais sur les impacts de main
d'oeuvre je pense pas je pense qu'on est
pas encore là dans les réflexions jean
milliards mais il ya une possibilité je
pense avoir encore plus de formations et
de requalification des chômeurs pour les
préparer à la nouvelle réalité du marché
du travail mais il ya aussi la question
de cette réforme là qu'est ce qu'on va
faire de l'assurance emploi dans les
prochaines années on a des déficits
actuariels important à combler
l'africain julian fin d'une fin du gel
des cotisations des employeurs l'année
prochaine avec des empereurs qui se
posent des questions si on a fait un
programme plus large socialement c'est
bien mais qui va payer pour ça oui
exactement bien on aura peut-être une
mise à jour économique bientôt et
budgétaire puis un budget de toute façon
dans un gouvernement minoritaire il
semblerait qu'on prépare toujours la
prochaine élection donc faut rester vph
est actif mia hamm si charles milliards
merci est assez rare pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit